tragedy for broadway star megan hilty
her sister brother-in-law and their
child killed in a plane crash off the
coast of seattle on sunday the coast
guard says the northwest sea plane's
flight left friday harbor in the san
juan islands and was in flight to the
renton municipal airport that's the
company's base but the plane never made
it it went down around 3 pm in mutiny
bay off whidbey island megan's sister
lauren was also pregnant at the time of
the accident seven other people died in
the crash which is still under
investigation the coast guard says that
no distress call ever went out it was
somebody monitoring the flight over that
home base in renton that noticed
something was off lauren and her husband
ross andrew mickles family released a
statement tuesday calling the couple a
bright and shining light in the lives of
everyone who knew them they go on to
thank emergency responders investigators
and private citizens who helped in the
rescue efforts following the crash megan
has yet to speak out on her own because
i knew you
beyond broadway megan's best known for
her work on the nbc series smash you're
in the wrong business understudy she was
also in last year's production of annie
live and played country music icon patsy
cline in the 2019 lifetime movie patsy
and loretta i knew
[Music]
you want it
early enough patsy died in a plane crash
in 1963.
i think any time you play a real person
you you owe them a certain
well a lot of respect and i wanted to do
her justice and her family justice
somehow
[Music]